dans le kit
on va retrouver le patron le patron
couture qui permet de faire le sac comme
avec ce sac ali dominique riboud propose
35 modèles de kits tissu extérieur tissu
intérieure et la maroquinerie dans un
pack tout ce qu'il faut pour créer
soi-même son sac
une idée que cette créatrice saint
germanoise imagine il ya 20 ans j'avais
envie de me transmettre aux couturières
et puis surtout je me suis attaché à
chercher les matières les matériaux qui
manque aux couturières il ya des modèles
pour les débutantes donc on va partir
effectivement sur des formes droites sur
des petits cabba et puis au fil des
années j'ai bien vu que les couturières
avait besoin de passer à des modèles
plus sophistiqués donc avec des choix
des tissus plus sophistiquées ou alors
des formes aussi arrondi avec des
fronces et c'est dominique propose
chaque année deux collections fonction
des saisons est décliné en plusieurs
couleurs
une gamme de prix entre 35 et 59 euros
passer d'abord par le vêtement dominique
se lance il ya 20 ans dans la création
de sacs à main
ça plaît à tout le monde n'y a pas de
problème de taille
la créativité sur le sac à main elle est
énorme les modèles parfois n'ont pas
bougé il est toujours des intemporels
jour des modèles très plébiscité mais ce
sont les tissus je vais changer cinq à
six modèles peuvent sortir de son
atelier chaque année des sacs de toutes
les tailles à peut-être offrir avec
malice un de ses proches